well while you're chowing down on your
Thanksgiving feast here's some food for
thought according to running USA
Thanksgiving is the most popular running
day in the country and Las Vegas is no
different this morning nearly 800 people
are warming up at the annual wobble
before you gobble Thanksgiving run
taking place at Kellogg's Air Park
Candace Charles is there with us this
morning it looks like you're warming up
too give us the details of this run
Candace
well well Sherry I'm running in place
because you let it be windy out here so
now I'm cold but you guys can come down
here and run of course to maybe lose a
little bit way before you fill up your
stomach with the turkey and the ham I'm
getting hungry just thinking about it as
you can see we're near the Finish Line
This Is Where folks want to get to we
hear it's going to be 800 people out
here doing at the turkey chat and of
course it's all for a great cause
Achilles Las Vegas and I'm joined by
Kelly's Las Vegas Crystal Gallery thank
you so much for joining us this morning
tell us a little bit about the charity
so Achilles International works with
blind and disabled athletes so that
they're able to participate in
mainstream athletic events like a Turkey
Trot we have weekly training runs twice
a week now one in Summerlin on Saturdays
and then we're in Henderson on Sunday
mornings and we also pair our athletes
with guides that go with them through
the races we work to raise funds so that
we can pay for the race entries because
so many disabled people are living on
disability wouldn't be able to pay for
those things otherwise we put them in
new shoes proper athletic gear all those
good things and just you know we really
just have a good time when we're out
training and then celebrate on race day
so nice well it sounds like it's going
to be a fun time out here I know you
guys did the 4th of July race with these
folks so I know you're expecting to
raise quite a bit of funds how will this
help you guys around this time of year
um well definitely right now as it's
getting windy and cold I'm noticing a
lot of new athletes that we gained this
year don't have but they don't have the
warm weather or the cold weather gear to
keep warm yeah so this is going to help
us get like beanies mittens little hand
warmers things like that and well I can
tell you Christy it's cold so I know
that'll definitely be helpful and I
heard that you're actually a runner as
well you got any tips for me really
quickly or for the folks coming out here
to run
um just keep going just keep smiling I
love it Christy I love the energy thank
you for all the work you're doing in the
community and have a lot of fun out here
guys you have plenty of time to register
as you can see they're still getting set
up the race the wobbling starts at about
8 00 a.m this morning of course we got
to cover all details on our website
newsnow.com you guys I'm talking back to
you in the studio hopefully you guys are
not stuffing your face maybe you'll have
to come out here and run as well